REELS STOMPS FAKE.
>> MORE THAN PUMP PAST ELECTIONS
.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT COMMON
SENSE AND FELT LEFT OUT A
REJECTION OF IT.
YOU AGREE?
>> THE THING IS, THERE IS AN
NORMA'S DISCONNECT OF THOSE IN
WASHINGTON AND THOSE ON THE
GROUND.
IN KENTUCKY, WE LOST 40 PEOPLE
TO SEVERE FLOODING RECENTLY.
HUNDREDS OF HOMES WE'RE LOST.
I WAS JUST OUT THERE, NOT ONE
PERSON SAID CAN YOU PLEASE SEND
MORE MONEY TO UKRAINE.
THEY SAID HOW COME WE ARE A RIC
COMPETENT COUNTRY AND HAVING
TROUBLE DIGGING OUR DITCHES,
REPAIRING OUR ROADS, ANOTHER
13 BILLION AFTER THEY SEND THIS
13 BILLION, WE WILL SEND OVER
$50 BILLION TO UKRAINE AND
PEOPLE IN EASTERN KENTUCKY OUR
SAYING HOW COME WE CAN'T REPAIR
OUR BRIDGES, HOW CAN WE CAN'T
REPAIR OUR ROADS.
I FIND NOBODY IN KENTUCKY SAYIN
PLEASE SEND MORE OF OUR MONEY
OVERSEAS.
YOU'VE GOT DEMOCRATS PLEASE SEN
MORE MONEY TO UKRAINE.
I'M NOT HEARING IT AT HOME AT
ALL.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT THAT
DISCONNECT, SENATOR.
TODAY, BIDEN WITH ONE OF HIS
SO-CALLED ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
>> THEY ARE MAKING THE JAVELIN
MISSILE, THAT WE ARE SUPPLYING
TO UKRAINE.
SENATOR, HOW DOES THE PRODUCTIO
OF THE JAVELIN MISSILES FOR
UKRAINE HELP AMERICANS?
>> I'VE NEVER REALLY BEEN BIG O
LOOKING AT ARMS PROGRAMS AS JOB
PROGRAMS.
I THINK THAT OUR WEAPONS ARE
UNIQUELY EITHER TAXPAYER, EVEN
THE PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY SHOULD BE SOMETHING, LET'S
GIVE MORE WEAPONS TO CREATE JOB
BY GETTING INVOLVED IN OVERSEAS.
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE THE MONEY
TO DO THIS.
WE ARE $30 TRILLION IN THE HALL
HOLE, AND ITS INFLATIONARY.
AROUND KENTUCKY AND AROUND THE
U.S. IS MY GAS COST SO MUCH WE
CAN GO ON VACATION THIS YEAR.
THE GROCERIES COST SO MUCH
BRIGHT I'M A SENIOR CITIZEN, MY
CHECK IS GETTING THINNER AND
THINNER.
I CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THE THINGS
I WANT TO DO BECAUSE OF
INFLATION.
THEY ALL INSTINCTIVELY KNOW THI
IS FROM THE MASSIVE DEBTS, THE
MASSIVE BORROWING, AND THE HUGE
COVID LOCKDOWNS AND AUTHOR
STATES THAT WERE FOISTED UPON U
BY DEMOCRATS, BY BIDEN, BY THE
DEMOCRAT CONGRESS.
THERE IS A HUGE WAVE BUILDING.
I THINK THEY'RE STILL A A HUGE
WAVE OF DISCONTENT AND PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO WANT TO THROW THE
PEOPLE OUT TWO BECAUSE OF THIS
INFLATION.
YOU'VE GOT YOUR OWN RACE IN
TENNESSEE, BUT YOU'VE GOT A
HEALTHY LEAD.
>> I'M I CAN.
>> I GOT YOU.
>> FIGHTING HARD IN KENTUCKY AN
THINGS ARE NARROWING ACROSS THE
U.S.
WE ARE FIGHTING HARD TO LET
PEOPLE KNOW THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT KIND OF REPUBLICAN.
I KIND OF REPUBLICAN THAT ALSO
SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M GOING T
GIVE MONEY BACK TO THE TREASURE
FOR MY OFFICE.
AND NOT GOING TO SPEND ALL THE
MONEY THEY GIVE ME.
MY OFFICE HAS GIVEN BACK OVER
$5 MILLION TO THE TREASURY.
>> THAT IS AWESOME.
I'M GOING TO TWEET OUT YOUR NEW
AD WHICH I JUST SAW, WHICH IS
FANTASTIC GREAT I DON'T KNOW WH
MADE THAT AD FOR YOU, BUT
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO BE CURIOUS
SO THEY WILL HAVE TO GO TO MY